gefährliche sonnen aufnahmen feuer in
riesigen teleskop und aufnahmen der
sonne aus dem 12 5 und 3 millimeter
wellenlängenbereich jetzt
weiterentwickelt huck ja nicht mit der
kamera den sie in die sonne werk kennt
darf nicht und schon gar nicht mit einer
kamera in die sonne zu gucken ist nicht
ganz ungefährlich
dementsprechend ist es auch nicht gerade
ungefährlich die sonde mit teleskopen zu
untersuchen wie der future noch
überzeugt so berichtet brach tatsächlich
schon mal am sekundär spiegelte
schwedischen die submillimeter teleskope
ein feuer aus nachdem das teleskop
verdient sich auf die bühne gerichtet
wurde
jetzt konnte man aber ohne schäden
völlig neue aufnahmen der
sonnenoberfläche machen mit hilfe des
atacama large millimeter submillimeter
array alma entschieden von experten
einen sensationellen sonnenfleck
fotografieren hier seht ihr einmal den
vom fleck im 125 millimeter
wellenlängenbereich und jetzt den
sonnenfleck nochmal in drei
millimeterwellen überreicht das ist
schon sensationell aus aber was bedeutet
diese errungenschaft jetzt für die
forschung zitat wir sind den anblick
unserer sonne im sichtbaren licht
gewohnt aber dies kann uns nicht alles
über die dynamische oberfläche und
atmosphäre unseres sterns verraten um
die sonne ganz zu verstehen müssen wir
sie im gesamten elektromagnetischen
spektrum untersuchen darunter auch im
millimeter- und submillimeterbereich dem
alma abdeckt so team bastian vom us
national video apple mama operatoren
schaffen will
übrigens wenn die sonne jetzt in diesem
moment einfach verschwinden würde wäre
uns das ganze acht minuten lang egal
denn das licht was von der sonne kommt
benötigt trotz
die geschwindigkeit acht minuten um die
distanz von etwa 150 millionen
kilometern zu durchqueren
eine umlaufbahn gäbe es ohne unsere
sonne jahren natürlich auch nicht doch
genauso wie beim licht würde die erde
ebenfalls erst nach acht minuten die
umlaufbahn verlassen da die gravitation
fällen ebenfalls mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit unterwegs
somit würde die erde ohne die sonne noch
acht minuten lang um sie kreisen nach
etwa einer woche wäre die temperatur die
durchschnittstemperatur auf der erde am
gefrierpunkt angelangt ja es würde also
echt schnell einig und ungemütlich
werden und zwar überall auf der erde
ganz gemütliche kriegs um videos in die
abo box bekommt man übrigens in dem wir
uns hier kostenlos abonniert und ich
freue mich auch über dafür einen daumen
nach oben und ansonsten bislang geplant